so let's take a step back
to uh roswell we talked about a little
bit what's your sense about that whole
time
roswell and just area 51 and
the sightings and also the follow-on
mythology around those sightings
um that's with us today all right so
where do i get started well i mean it is
a mythology here right
the mythology of roswell it's it's very
religious like in the sense that
there's a pilgrimage to roswell people
make and they go
to there's a festival there as well like
a religious
festival um you could get little kitschy
stuff like you can get at a religious
festival
there so it's very much like a place of
pilgrimage where a herophony occurred
and a herophamy is basically contact
with non-human intelligence
okay so non-human intelligence is
thought to have contacted
humans or crashed at this place in
roswell new mexico
now what's fascinating is that i begin
my book
by going out to a crash site in new
mexico i have to get blindfolded
with my well to tell you the truth
the story is that i'm with tyler who's
an invisible and he wants to show me a
place in new mexico where a crash
happened
and he says that he thinks that i need
to see physical evidence because i don't
believe and so
i said i'll go but i'm going to bring a
friend of mine and he said no you have
to go alone he goes it's a it's a
place that is on government-owned
property
and it's a no-fly zone and when you go
you'll be blindfolded and
i said i definitely need to bring a
friend
[Laughter]
so he said well who do you want to bring
i just had met
this university scientist who's very
well known
and i call him james in my book and i
asked and i
had a feeling james would definitely
want to do this and i asked james and he
said i'll go tomorrow
okay so i suggested this to tyler and
tyler
said absolutely not you know and i
thought
i know he's going to look up james and
he's going to say yes because if anybody
can figure out what
this material is that we're going to go
look for it's going to be james
he has the instruments and so tyler did
in fact look him up and finally said
okay i got
you can go so we both head out there and
we get blindfolded and tyler takes us
out there it takes about 40 minutes
um outside of a certain place in new
mexico so in terms of roswell this is
what i can say
is that according to tyler there were
about seven crashes
out in the 1940s in new mexico in
various places um
we went to one of them according to
tyler
i at the time i was completely an
atheist with regard to anything that had
to do with the ufos
so we were out there we had specially
configured
metal detectors for these metals
and we did find these okay and
they've since been studied by various
scientists material scientists so forth
and um i believe jacques talked about
not those particular ones but others on
the joe rogan show um there are no
anomalies so there are we uh scientists
don't i'm
i'm not a scientist so i can't weigh in
on
whether i just i just believe the people
these people i believe because
they're well-known scientists what do
you mean they're not anomaly so
no they are not they are not anomalous
oh anomalous in terms of the materials
that
are uh naturally occurring on earth yes
okay so that so there's some kind of
inklings of evidence that uh
that something happened
in roswell in terms of crashes of alien
technology
now what else is there to the mythology
so there's some
crashes right right yeah i mean that's
kind of epic
it's pretty epic yeah and uh
what else like what um what are we
supposed to take away from this right
yeah so it's weird okay so um there's
this
okay so in religious studies like i said
we call it a herophony
which is the meeting of a non-human
intelligent thing
whatever it is an angel a god whatever a
goddess
with or an alien with humans and that's
the place okay so the place is new
mexico
so we so new mexico becomes
folded into the mythology of this new
religion
is what i call a new type of religion um
of the ufo
and it becomes ground zero for this new
mythology
just like mecca is the is the place
where
muslims go they have to go right at
least once in their lives
it's a pilgrimage place now so this is
so in my book that's how i
i tell it now what about roswell in the
public imagination
um obviously according to annie
jacobson who's good you know she's a
great author
investigative journalist she's written
about roswell too i don't agree with all
of
what she comes up with but part of it is
that there's a lot of military stuff
going on there
that is classified and there's a reason
why you can't get in
and nor would you want to right so um
so there's a lot of experimentation
going on there
um i don't believe that it's has to do
with ets frankly
but in the imaginations of americans
roswell is that place but i went to a
different place
and apparently there are several places
in new mexico now strangely enough
i travel back to new mexico at the very
end chapter
of my book but it's not it i don't i
don't go there physically
i go there through the story of a
catholic
uh nun who actually believes that she
bilocated
to new mexico in the
gosh in the 1600s so she
yeah it was very strange and i was at
the vatican at the space observatory
when i made that connection that she
probably went to the very
well she believed she went to this very
place that i had gone
can you uh can you elaborate in a little
bit like what does it mean to go to that
place
yeah yeah for for her i mean we're kind
of
uh breaking down
the barrier between what it means to be
at a place in time
right i agree with you uh this is the
field of religious studies
so and again i don't say it's true in my
book i just say it's a very strange
coincidence
that i'm at the vatican observatory in
fact i'd finished my book
but while i was at the vatican
observatory i was there with tyler
and we were looking at the records that
can't they're called the trial records
but they're the canonization records
of these two saints each was said to
have done
amazing things one was joseph of
cupertino who levitated
okay is said to have levitated the other
was
maria of agrada from spain their
contemporaries in the 1600s
who was said to have been able to buy
locate which is to be in two places at
once
okay so this is a belief in catholicism
that certain very holy people can do
these kinds of things like levitate
which by the way is also associated with
ufo abductions you know
people get levitated out of their beds
and things like that so we were sent
there
by a billionaire who was interested in
levitation and by location and since i
could get into the vatican and i knew
the director of the vatican observatory
both tyler and i were able to go to the
secret archives
and look at the canonization records and
then go to
castle gandolfo which is about an hour
from the vatican where the first
observatory
the space observatory of the vatican
is the second one is in arizona it has a
much larger telescope
so we went and we and brother guy gave
me the keys to the archive
i said look at anything you want i got
to see a lot of stuff by carl sagan by
the way
i know you talked about yeah it was
awesome so they have a whole section on
extraterrestrial the search for
extraterrestrial life
and they don't by the way how awesome is
that it was awesome yeah
so we got to stay there they have a
scholars quarters yeah and so
they had two and so tyler stayed in one
and i stayed in the other
and brother guy probably shouldn't have
been so nice to me and given me the um
the keys because i i when i got home we
were there
for two weeks when i got home i got this
frantic phone call from him and he
basically said
diana he goes do you remember where you
put the original
kepler and so i had this kepler right
and so i misplaced it
luckily i remembered where it went i was
like oh gosh
thank goodness i found it but he'll
probably change the rules of the vatican
observatory after my visit
so maria is she's actually in the
history
of uh our country in that she
first wrote a cosmography of
um what she said was the spinning earth
and this was in the 1600s
and she that's her first book and she
wrote that
and then she said that she was
transported on the wings of angels to
the new world
and she said that she met a culture
of people and she um basically told them
about
the faith of catholicism okay and then
what happened was that
the people that and she described the
fauna she described the people
and everything like that and so there
were actually missionaries there
and when they went to try to
convert some of the people who already
lived there
apparently they already knew a bunch of
stuff and they said how did you know all
this stuff and they said
uh this lady in blue came and told us
and they said did it look like this and
they showed them they obviously didn't
have a photograph
but they had a picture of a sister
a nun and they said yes they she wore
similar clothes but she was much younger
right
and these guys were you know thought
that was weird but when they went back
to spain
they found that this woman had been
doing that in her mind
had been traveling i mean i don't know
what to make of it there's so many
things that are sort of
forcing you to kind of go outside of
um you know i'm of many minds i have a
very
most of my days spent with very rigorous
scientific
kind of things and even engineering kind
of things and then
i'm also open-minded and just
the the entirety of the idea of
extraterrestrial life forces you to
think outside of
conventional boundaries of thought
scientific
current scientific thought let's put it
that way and your story right now is
something exciting it's freaking you out
that's okay that's a nice way to put it
you